[Music]
hello
i decided that i wasn't going to make
any decideds at all even though i
decided to make it decided today that
doesn't count as it decided because it
isn't actually a decision i don't like
making choices and i'm anathema to
commitment therefore i shall let an
uh
computer algorithm that is intended to
do random number generation decide my
fate for me
[Music]
i'm saying terrible things amy
i'm saying i'm on a bad roll
one could say that i'm tumbling down
a mountain but that's kind of how i want
to live my life i don't want to try to
grab for any rock that's going to help
me like stop my random descent into
madness as i careen into the ravine
and doom and random chance
i want to live life by grabbing the
balls of life
and
we were all born from a sack of random
right
our father's ball sack
and it's many millions of possible sperm
one of them was us we were random chance
so what who am i to make an actual
decision and think that i'm better than
my own dad's balls this is a great start
i'm going to play a random game
i don't want to play in just
okay so
the thing is that's not that can't be
random
these are not random games this is not
rand no way and there's no way that was
random what i want is this i found this
shady looking website and i clicked this
wheel and it came up with a game called
shadow wolf mysteries bane of the family
collectors edition which
i don't know what the hell that is
bane of
the
baman bane of the family to refuse now
see that's random
that
that's random
that is random okay i'm gonna save this
though because i didn't spin the wheel
on camera and how could you guys know
that it was actually random unless i
spin the wheel in front of you which i'm
gonna do right now and as far as i know
this is pretty damn random because that
test said that it was pretty random
why is there music playing this is how
you know it's kind of a shady website
because this is just like
you don't do automatic playing website
on any reputable website
earth attack now
i'm just gonna put this in my cart yoink
all right earth whoa hey what's going on
here
[Laughter]
okay earth attack
now that's a goddamn random game
no user reviews
this
looks
amazing
blur my face too okay i did it these are
now forever in my collection i'm going
to install them all right so i'm not
actually going to play shadow wolf
mysteries i just got it because it was a
random one and i don't know why i just
felt like it but i've spent now 20 bucks
on random games that who knows when the
last time they had a sale was but earth
attack was the randomly assigned game
that destiny smiled upon me to
bless me with it had no reviews and
that's how you know it's random right
because the other ones that that steam
was actually giving me that's not random
clearly it's not random it's still
curated so number one steam you've been
exposed because your random button isn't
actually random you liars and number two
shady website that actually picks random
games might also just be a thing where
game developers put in black please let
someone play my game but if i play this
not only am i going to play it and do a
full let's play on earth attack but i am
also going to leave a review of my
entire experience with this game
released september 14th 2020 by ptw who
has also made such great games as flappy
bee ball fall turret defense bug
invasion halloween escape and angry rock
but let's kick off this adventure of
possibly
earth attack
earth is attacked by unknown adversaries
the only fighter left in the mars colony
star base is left to tackle the journey
alone and must traverse to earth avoid
asteroids missiles and seekerships to
make this voyage safely and earn as many
points as possible am i recording
correctly
god i hope so i don't want to miss any
of this all right
lixian
this looks like a game you might have
made
you remember did you uh steal the idea
from them i don't care if this game came
out after you made your game that i
definitely remember the name of it oh
god please look oh god what was it
what was the name of it
what was the name of your game you're a
great game it was it was a good game i
liked it i did a video on it
not the game that you made for me oh
oh
what was it
shmoophams it was called shmoop'em ups
oh no
oh it had the log
blast ass i think it was called blast
ass i'm gonna go blast ass all right
what do i do what do i do
oh
man i'm slow
oh i just dodged do i not shoot
do do i not shoot oh
ow
is there
so there's no way to def ow that oh hey
whoa hey whoa hey buddy hey wait wait a
minute wait
what uh okay so there's a you can't move
two directions at once that's the
strange thing
uh and apparently i can't there's
i can't go forward more than that okay
[Music]
okay
so i'm trying to get in character here
the earth is under attack
my family
my friends
oh oh god oh my god
oh my god why who in what world is that
fair
[Music]
so all my friends and family are dead
because i couldn't make it back but how
can i alone shipship or possibly do
anything to stop the incredible
death-defying
horribleness that could be falling bb
falling could be befalling my friends
and family back home
that's what i'm not
and what is
how is there any way to go faster
there really is no way to avoid
these dudes
maybe there's another button that i'm
not aware of it didn't even remember my
high score
my my high score it didn't remember my
high score well whatever you know what
it's okay
i'm trying to be positive about and here
comes the game over
section i guess
you literally cannot move faster
than those you can't move faster than
those
great
while not
what most people would define
as a
complete
game
earth
attack
does have some semblance
of a challenge to its
loosely
defined structure
the peril of
the peril and futility
structure
[Music]
the peril and futility of one lone pilot
with no
with no weapons
might i add attempting
to save the entirety
of
earth of earth
from an alien
invasion is
properly expressed
however
i'm apparently not
skilled enough to beat it and the game
thought
that my measly
score wasn't even worthy of writing to
memory therefore
therefore
do i recommend this game
no
yes no yes no yes no i do not yes i do
[Music]
my word is law
there we go all right so that was a
terrible
great
use of my time and just another fact uh
in the long line of history of how
random chance can lead you to greatness
hey
random is where it's at all right can
you give me can you give me something
else can you give me something maybe a
little bit more um
actually a game
uh than anything that you have given me
thus far
[Music]
replayable endless arcade style game
loop space alien ships missiles
asteroids core attack okay i didn't even
read the description okay sophisticated
puzzles relaxing puzzle game easy logic
gameplay only mouse to play 50 beautiful
puzzles to solve blur that email
sophisticated
okay i'm much more real
[Music]
[Music]
some of you who may have been following
my channel's history might know that
i've done those types of puzzles
at many junctures throughout my career
as a youtube let's player and you may
know that i
have a particular affinity and and um
likitudeness of playing those types of
games but maybe this one has some
pleasant music playing in the background
inventory
and i crashed because i didn't have any
inventory in the first place that was my
fault i should have known better i will
know better next time 3x3 please
[Music]
no no
no
no
no
[Music]
no
no
no
no no no
no
no no no
no
no no
no no
no i consider myself to be a pretty
smart guy you know i consider myself to
be a relatively smart dude
but these puzzles just don't make any
god damn sense to me i can't wrap my
head around them they don't work for my
brain they just don't go and i hate them
i hate them i hate them and guess what
i also hate them god
oh my god
oh my god and i know that i have been
probably out of frame this entire
goddamn video but i do not care because
i just cannot
get these goddamn puzzles they don't
make
i'm a genius and i am a god and all will
know my glory
all will know my glorious glory
[Music]
success is almost nice
success is
[Music]
uh
[Music]
now how would you get over there
[Music]
no you're backwards
[Music]
oh god oh okay okay okay
there's no fanfare
[Music]
okay
i recommend this game thank you
well my adventure in terms of playing
random games on steam ended exactly the
way that i expected it to well with
memory memory memory memories with many
memories and many memories to come
i feel great for my not choices and it's
about not choices that create the most
memories if anything's ever taught us
anything in life is that random chance
is the great equalizer because it sucks
and is great in equal measures so if you
guys want to see another video like
this maybe i'll get a good game i mean
not saying those weren't good games i
recommended them to everybody and i
recommend them and you'll find the links
in the description below but i'm done
because i have to go film
the sequel to a heist with markiplier
and if i go into there with rage in my
heart then i will not survive the
experience playing that
filming that not playing that hope you
have a good day out there there's plenty
of games in the sea so many games so
many games
go check them out for yourself and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye bye
[Music]
you